hello folks how's everybody hope you're
doing fine and happy new year in advance
okay best lead to the people who support
this program I want to thank them for
supporting it this year not everybody
agrees with what everybody would I say
with all the theories I proposed but one
thing I can guarantee you come here by
you know through the grapevine or
whatever way you found about this site
I'm going to give you a run for your
money in other words I'm going to give
you a different theory a different
explanation for thing I always say that
I'm not human and I'm not human because
I don't think like any other human out
there I don't know what people have in
their minds but yeah I have a different
way of thinking and so again if you come
into the site you may not agree with
what I say but you're going to be
entertained to a new way of looking at
the universe okay
and one of those subjects is a subject
of extinction I have an exhausted
extinction by by no no means obviously
by the questions and the comments that I
get but I don't want to exhaust the
visitors right the viewers so today's my
last installment on this series next
week next time I'm going to end with an
R & R there was one episode I did not
cover and I'm gonna go over that just
before I finished with Ain Rand as well
and then we're gonna get back into what
this channel is mostly about which is
physics and what a lot of people usually
come the site for okay
but today it's another extinction day so
if you've got something better to do
well don't do it okay stick around you
might learn something
okay so here we go let's start with the
comments okay we had a comment here my
one thought he says and man became the
god that he had created and with his
miracles did rule over all deeper
hallelujah and amen and all that good
stuff you know yeah I mean I think he
hit it pretty much on the nose who we we
don't even think we're animals anymore a
lot of people don't out there they think
somehow we belong to some other Kingdom
rocks and minerals or vegetables I don't
know but yeah we become the rulers of
the planet and forgot that we are not
the gardeners God did not designate us
as the gardeners of Eden we are just
another little animal in in there okay
that's my take on that one and so
getting back to extinction here's a
comment that some people make and I said
that when the Academy totally collapses
by which I mean money is no more and
trade has died that's what I mean when I
say the economy collapses I'm not
talking about a temporary depression or
recession I'm talking about total
destruction of money you don't use money
anymore we have no need or not need but
money has no purpose okay Bessy to pay
salaries which means no one has anything
to spend and money does not get sir
circled around and so I said no one will
have an incentive to produce food
because of that and that's the key issue
for my extinction theory I'm saying that
we're gonna die because we're not we
cannot avoid the same thing that claimed
the lives of past animals that became
extinct okay and so someone put the
incentive is wanting to live another one
said money is hardly the strongest
motivation to produce food well these
people are actually I think they're
focusing on the wrong issue the issue is
not whether that you want to live in the
issue is not whether money is a good
motivation for you I'm talking about
corporations here corporations they have
no interest in wanting you to live or be
healthy or anything like that
corporations are only interested in
profit
it's that's called money okay and so
money is hardly the song as motivation
it's the only motivation sorry you know
we're not talking about the individual
here we're talking about corporations
the one who the people the the things or
the entities that run the planet okay
those are known as corporations
individuals little individuals the
little guy there that does this thing on
the streets he's not running the world
the world is run by corporations make no
mistake about that okay and someone says
even if we stop harvesting land and
animals we can make food to live on by
technology and I think I don't know it's
the same guys that food can be made from
coal and high voltage yeah that's in a
lab setting you cannot manufacture food
in your garage especially not at the
last moment when suddenly food stops
being provided to the cities and so no
no forget about producing food
artificially that's that's okay to do it
in a lab and say look we were able to
produce this thing that is edible and we
were able to get some carbon and some
hydrogen together and make this thing
those are special situations we're not
gonna produce food chemically in the
future we're going to do it the way the
old-fashioned way the way we always did
it and that's growing it in the field
and with animals and so on
it's like saying we can create an animal
you know FSE to feed eight billion
people it's not gonna happen these
people are dreaming okay and again I
think a lot of people just are floating
in air they don't have their feet on the
ground anymore here's another comment
along the same lines as far as I'm
concerned so they'd only takes a few
humans to repopulate so they're saying
even if there is a crash and a lot of
people die I don't know half the
population three-quarters the population
someone will survive and will reproduce
will repopulate the earth again okay
next guy says about the same thing worst
case scenario population grows to ten
yeah 3/4 of the Earth's population dies
eventually the remaining humans will
start all over I think you know this
Adam and Eve type thing okay and in fact
he says so they're gonna be have an
advantage because they're gonna have all
this previous knowledge right and and so
they're gonna be better off and he puts
a common zero population growth does not
mean we can't have any more babies but
we choose to have fewer babies it's not
an issue of choice women don't have
choice to have babies anymore okay get
it through your thick skull women don't
have choice care did you hear me women
don't have choice why don't they have
choice because we moved from the country
to the city there is no room in the
cities for babies you can have one baby
two babies that's it you're not gonna
have ten babies like in the 19th or 18th
centuries when people lived in the farms
that that era is over the baby era is
over okay we considered a baby boom what
happened after World War two and that
was just a little drop baby boom no more
boom okay and that's because we moved to
the cities when people moved to the
cities it doesn't matter they're black
yellow white they won't have any more
babies women will not have babies and it
it becomes also part of the culture
where people say well I'm not gonna have
a baby a lot of women today will tell
you straight straight in your face
they're not they think it's an animal
thing having babies what do you think I
am an animal so now no more babies
that's never gonna happen again okay the
era of babies is over and so yeah we're
not gonna repopulate the planet and one
of the reasons is here let's assume
someone survives on the planet well for
them to survive in different regions of
these pockets that means that everybody
died around them they can't be any other
way you're not going to have thousands
of people surviving in the same region
because they're just going to kill
themselves if there's no food okay so if
there's our family
because I can't even imagine a group of
strangers surviving they're gonna kill
each other but a family has a chance of
surviving and let's assume this family
is smart they survive there no region
winner where they were not attacked or
killed nay were able to grow some crops
okay they're gonna live on subsistence
farming and you know that they won't
have too many things at their disposal
okay they're probably not gonna have any
oil anymore any gas someone made by
someone okay so they won't be able to
run tractors or anything like that there
won't be any animals the plow so they're
gonna have to do it by hand like the
old-fashioned way
right that's if they survive and there
can't be anyone near them because these
pockets are going to be very very
isolated that means if they reproduce
they're generally produced locally and
let's say ten people survive above one
family let's say four of them are young
or five and out of those young people
okay so they produce a couple children
how long do you think it would take for
them to lose their genetic diversity
completely and end up in extinction
anyways I mean you know what people
don't understand is that we have lost
our genetic diversity and and that's
very hard for people to accept they said
what do you mean and here how do you get
an example okay this is a prime example
and and this is from Oxford University a
study that they made they went to Africa
and they checked three different tribes
or they're called troops of chimpanzees
and this was the conclusion that came
out of that say even though all the
chimpanzees live in relatively close
proximity chimpanzees from different
populations were substantially more
different genetically than humans living
on different continents that is despite
the fact that the habitus of the two
groups are separated only by a river it
speaks to the great genetic similarities
between human populations you know you
have a troop of chimps maybe fifty to a
hundred chimps
they have more genetic diversity than
all of the eight billion people on earth
and the reason for that is very simple
we were note species we're an old specie
we've been inbreeding for perhaps two
hundred thousand years if that's the
date you want to accept for the start of
the human race and so we've been
inbreeding for a long time and a species
as I explained in my book how the
Neanderthals disappeared at beginning it
gains genetic diversity as the groups of
people occupy different niches and get
accustomed to different environments but
after a while they start coming down and
we lose genetic diversity and we can
only lose genetic diversity because of
population bottlenecks followed by
founders effects and that series of
population bottlenecks followed by
founders effects
what it does is streamlines our genetic
code and yeah what what does it is
disease disease makes us all be the same
the reason Japanese has the same genetic
code as you do has nothing to do with
his grandfather marrying someone in your
family it's got to do with the fact that
we all went through the same sifting
process we all conquered the same kinds
of diseases our ancestors did and today
we're all the same we're all clones
marry whom you marry he's your brother
or she's your sister genetically that's
how how Cloney we are okay so no we're
not going to restart the population if
if we have a crash the people who
survive will just live out their lives
and that's it besides the psychological
effect of having no one on planet Earth
just imagine that just do it on your own
right think about it and yeah here's
another comment that was made and says
that they quoted this person saying
historically infertility has been
falling across Europe if we took if we
look at the most recent pee the last ten
years or so we see rises in four
in most advanced countries well I don't
know who this professor is but she's got
it wrong she's got it wrong because the
population pyramid is overturning no
matter what we do on planet earth and
here here I showed and this is this is
the true rate growth rate for population
on Earth by mid-century we're going to
reach zpg zero population growth we're
going to have babies but the you know
where the population is not going to
grow because we're going to have very
few babies and lots of deaths okay
that's one issue and then I showed the
population curve for any species and I'm
saying this is my population curve you
can challenge it if you want but
essentially what I'm saying is that when
a species starts out it has this very
young pyramid which is very few young
people and LA I'm sorry lots of young
people very few old people and births
are up and deaths are up there are both
high you know they just spit out kids
and they everybody dies very young and
then as time goes by you know eventually
that's shifts over and we start having
we go from no nomads to to a sedentary
type of life we settle down we colonize
like we did in the sixteenth century
essentially we colonized the planet and
shortly after there as well and today
where we've colonized the entire planet
okay now the only place we can go is
outside of the earth but and that's not
going to happen for sure but then what
happens at that point once we settle
down as births go up and dust goes down
because we get used to the endemic
diseases okay and then today we don't
die of contagious diseases anymore but
that used to be the norm 200 years ago
and then at some point we even out were
burst and thus more or less you become
the same and that's when we get cpg so
your population growth and eventually
births go down drastically and deaths go
up and that's the end of the human race
okay that's my
shard for humans but that applies to any
species I think that's what happens when
species settle down become sedentary
okay in the end you don't have to agree
I'm not asking you to agree I'm asking
you to understand when I'm proposing you
can do your own research and find out if
any of that clicks with you okay okay
and here's also comment along the lines
that of repopulating the earth but I
like the first comment this person named
can we live without trade based on
current econ economy the only answer to
that question is no okay I like that
answer but then he says but if trade
stops tomorrow this will not be to
extinction so he's got a yes there so
people live with these contradictions
they don't even realize it but yeah
again talking about repopulating years
never gonna happen okay another person I
think the same person put something
about the coniferous good and comment
and says conifers conform to your
criteria of an old species yeah correct
Conover still survive yeah correct ten
percent still survive today okay why did
conifers survive but dinosaurs did not
sturdy at least some dinosaurs would
have survived and yeah all all conifers
did not disappear some did disappear
some of the ones I think Triceratops and
some of the Achilles ours and some of
these dinosaurs ate these herbivores in
the 65 66 67 million years ago they I
think they eat special types of cycads
they probably ate cycad yards Williams
Sonja's types of plants that did
disappear they're no longer around and
but even though they may have eaten some
other type of conifer because the
dinosaurs did grow in relation to the
conifers not too anxious firms gained a
they grew in relation to the gymnosperms
okay
and what you will find is this you know
what I showed last time is that we have
the traditions to rest real revolution
and what the angiosperms did they pushed
aside all the conifers site guides of
conifers ginkgos or conifers and other
gymnosperms ferns are not conifers but
they were an older species of plants and
again all of these got squashed out and
evicted by the angiosperms okay that's
the first thing I want to show the
second one is this that this this is the
map of where they found some of the last
dinosaurs especially the T Rexes and
this that's just a sample we have sue
which was picked up in that region in
South Dakota north of South Dakota and
she was the biggest one until Scotty
came around which was found in Lower
Canada there and the last dinosaurs died
really in Hell Creek in that region
that's words consider that they probably
made their last stand and you can see
that we have that what is known as the
cycad National Monument
in that corner of South Dakota it
doesn't exist anymore okay and the
reason it doesn't exist
the psychic National Forest was a
Petrified Forest of site cats
okay and people took so many samples
that there was nothing left and they
said well so much for the money but for
the for the museum for the outdoor
museum okay so yeah although the samples
managed a lot of taken by
paleontologists themselves and so the
issue here is the following if you look
at the map again here's here's the map
of what happened or what is believed to
have happened
you had the Western interior Seaway and
you can see where South Dakota is there
right at the lower left-hand corner
and yeah the Western corner there and
and what happened to the Western
interior Seaway has dried up over five
million years and left that little lake
or you can call it a river almost right
going into the ocean and you can see
that the Hell Creek were maybe the last
dinosaurs were we're separated from the
cycad forests now I'm not saying this is
exactly what happened all I'm saying is
you can have a forest somewhere where
the animals can't find it for whatever
reason they're geographically or
physically isolated from that forest and
so it doesn't mean that because there
were sy cats that the animals had access
to those sites maybe they were somewhere
else or they were separated by some
river or whatever and so it doesn't
follow that because cycads were still
around that some dinosaurs would have
survived you know I think you have this
implosion of the entire herbivore
population the fewer and fewer cycads
there are and I think this is primarily
what they hate they probably were
specialized like we are today also you
know kids today you'll need hamburgers
you know or fast food they love that you
tell them you're gonna take them to
Kentucky Fried Chicken or McDonald's and
boy they'll be up front they want to go
but you say look you gotta eat your soup
and I don't think I like that so we're
picky eaters and I think the lot of
their hair rewards towards the end
become picky eaters as well maybe they
just ate the cones instead of eating the
plants you know I mean all these details
are things that need to be theorized
about I'm not even sure you find any
evidence of that for sure you're gonna
find evidence of everything out there
okay so where does this take us well the
other day I covered this situation where
we had this planet known as Omni trade
[Music]
again what I suggested it the same thing
that I was just saying about the
dinosaur maybe they were isolated from
their food and so what was the issue
with the Omni traders well it was that
suddenly there was a volcanic eruption
and the ocean disappeared and in its
stead we had these tall mountains okay
they were separated from their food one
person put a comment in there saying I
love this one he said you said solution
to your omnitrex or your mount prevents
ships from enabling trade between
farmers and city folks solution city
folk invent a plane or rocket city folk
and boring machines I can't believe some
of these people they're not even in the
context not even in the ballpark why
didn't I think of that of course I
thought of that that's why me the
mountains all the way to the moon so
that they could go over it the you know
they didn't invent airplanes is that a
good answer
they had no boring machine or whatever
let me give you another example
you know five free wheelies these narcho
caps people who know everything about
econ economics you know we're on a ship
and the ship sinks and they survive and
they swim to shore
of course before they leave the ship
before it sings they they take the
treasure chest with them right because
that's important to them and and you
know the food that was in the kitchen
that went down to the ocean floor right
because they don't think about these
things so they go to shore and they have
all this treasure chests they have these
coins gold coins and diamonds and all
that stuff and you know buy after one
hours searching through the island and
you realize there's no food on that
island and there's no fish on that
island or dolphins or any other animal
that swims nearby they look at a little
map that they have may find that the
nearest island is a hundred kilometers
away a hundred miles away and that's the
only one that's got food and they can't
swim there for sure and they won't make
it there even if they did dry
you know fishy if they're starving so
the question is they have trade but they
don't have food to trade for that's the
issue here and so so the question we've
got is is not whether you find an
airplane in the island say oh now I can
go with the airplane and I have a
solution to the food problem issues
whether you're physically isolated from
food despite that you have trade trade
does not guarantee food and you need
food
you don't need trade believe me we used
to live on planet Earth
most most of human life was done by
hunter gathering and in trade they
didn't know what trade was some people
believe they did trade with an and of
those and so on you know again people
who are not on this planet they don't
have their feet on the ground no we had
no train until the Neolithic that's when
the trade began that's when we invented
trade until then we had no trade so we
don't need trade but we needed food for
sure and we have that situation pretty
much today you know we are isolated from
food you know you don't find food in the
city I mean on the highway you know on
the streets yeah you have to go to a
supermarket and someone brings it there
because he wants to make a profit
etcetera right the question is when
there is no more money okay
who's gonna bring the moon food over to
to the supermarket I mean you know the
truck driver yeah if he doesn't get paid
because money is no more because money
has no value where is he gonna bring it
for you to keep you healthy to keep you
alive is that the incentive you know he
might keep himself alive by going out
there with his truck and getting food
wherever he gets it always and say well
I'm gonna live you know but as far as
the people in the cities they could
starve he doesn't care about them he's
gonna take care of number one and the
same for the corporations they're not
gonna produce food if money is no more
aside from the fact that they have to
kick all their employees out because
money
no more they have nothing to pay them
with and the workers not going to work
for nothing and so on down the line so
money is necessary to keep our economy
going
what is our economy today trade Commerce
what is Commerce Commerce is ABS economy
you're not producing anything new all
you're doing is exchanging existing
goods or services right which again is
nothing there's nothing there
you know I waved my hand and I get paid
the other person sings great singer and
gets paid okay and we all just put money
around and nothing is left after all
that you might say well there's a value
in my heart I I I listen to a beautiful
song it's nonsense there's nothing there
the only thing the only way we can
produce more wealth which is material
things is by using the service economy
to stimulate agriculture and
manufacturing okay so there is a
relationship in that sense but services
does not produce wealth directly only
indirectly through manufacturing and
through agriculture agriculture only
when there's more people because you
can't produce more food than necessary
and you can't produce less food than
necessary agriculture is a you know food
is a commodity which has to be just
right it's a Goldilocks II commodity it
can't be too much of it and can't be too
little of it you know Bill Gates doesn't
eat ten times more than I do because
he's got ten times more money right okay
so I hope you understand that and so
yeah food has to be just right but if
the population grows then you saw more
food right and so in that sense yeah
food grows in proportion to the
population but but again you only
produce more food if there's more people
and you produce other goods manufactured
goods again if there are more people and
if there's demand but you're producing
something something that remains
when you make a highway when you make a
building when you produce a machine
you're producing something when you
produce a service you're producing
absolutely nothing all you're doing is
exchanging existing information whatever
there's nothing there nothing solid
there okay people don't understand that
you know and all these three Willys they
don't care they say well it's value they
talk about value they don't talk about
things they talk about concepts and they
think these concepts are going to keep
us alive forever that's that's where the
worry is okay they don't see at least
what I see anyways I continue on here if
we're going to rely on manufacturing we
need to know what an invention is
because manufacturing and technology
depend on inventions okay and so this
person chooses me and a couple of them
did here
I'm not defining invention and and
they're right I have to have it to them
you know I never defined the word
invention I had no definition I had only
intuition of what an invention is and
that's why I say that there have been no
invention since about 1980s when we
invented the computer in other words
when we had a working computer and since
then there's been no inventions all we
had is modifications to devices that
carry their computers television radio
telephone all we did is just play around
with these things and put them into
different ways and one of them is the
cell phone which is a all-in-one is
their software and invention absolutely
not it's not an invention because the
phone was invented the computer had
already been invented the radio and
television all those have been invented
so the cell phone is just putting them
all together there's no new invention
it's just a development or what I call
an innovation okay and I'll get to that
in a second but here's this common said
for someone who is very particular about
definitions I think you are over
simplifying the definition to suit your
argument to a good slap in the face
love that and he says an invention he
uses the Wikipedia definitions and as an
invention is a unique or novel device
method composition or process the
invention process is a process within an
overall engineering and product
development process it may be an
improvement upon a machine or product or
a new process for creating an object or
a result all right now the person says
according to bill's definition of
advancement there can never be any new
inventions because everything that the
invention is made of already existed
before yes that's exactly what I'm
saying
okay I'm saying we cannot invent
anything new okay and we have not
invented anything new but again I did
not give you a definition of invention
so the slap in the face I deserved it
okay granted okay Touche okay
what are these files puts a list of
things that he thinks are inventions
over the last thirty years include
portable gps internet social media Wi-Fi
automated genome sequencer sequencer
Large Hadron Collider laser eye surgery
advanced robotics self-driving cars
drones digital photography LED lighting
protease inhibitors to treat HIV
artificial intelligence at cetera et
cetera okay and all those meet the
definition of the Wikipedia well I say
not one of those is an invention okay
and here's my counter-argument to that
okay see if I can go or let's put it
over here on the side so that you can
match them up okay self-driving car the
car was already invented portable gps we
had watches since the 17th century
internet social media Wi-Fi they're not
inventions because they are not
standalone
objects okay we're talking about
concepts they're not objects okay
surgery already invented by Galen 200 BC
HIV inhibitors medicines potions poisons
all kinds of stuff that we put in our
system they've been around since the
Neolithic again you know you
the witch doctors they give you all
kinds of potions okay photography
already embedded by Anissa for needs in
1826 the first guy who came up with a
camera Large Hadron Collider where we've
been accelerating particles at least
since Geiger probably even earlier 1908
robotics well the Greek engineers
savea's
about 270 BC applied pneumatics and
hydraulics to produce the first organ
and water clocks with moving figures
okay so you know and the question comes
up in whether the working device is is
what makes an invention or just a
concept here you have a one concept of
the robot for example and it was at
least invented by the Greeks they knew
about robots so they had the idea
because they put that god Hephaestus you
know he was the blacksmith of the gods
in Mount Olympus
he had already built the tripods that
walk to and from Mount Olympus and he
designed Hermes winged helmet and
sandals okay so so we've had the notion
of invention of a robot for a long time
and so the question is is is the
invention coming up with a concept or is
it coming up with a device that you can
patent at the Patent Office I mean can I
just go to the Patent Office without a
device and say look I've got this device
that I've got in my mind I don't think
so I think I have to take something
there okay so I'm just giving you some
hints of where I'm leading with us and
it's going to lead to my definition of
what a patent is okay
so let's let's look at some of the
differences between invention and
innovation at least my notion of them
and again I use the definitions of the
Wikipedia okay and inventors a unique or
novel device method composition or
process I'm saying that's not what an
invention is and you can see innovation
is a new idea creative thoughts new him
nations inform of device or method in
other words there's no difference
between invention and innovation
according to the Wikipedia they apply to
objects and concepts and I'm saying an
invention is only an object not a
concept okay we're talking about
material things versus abstractions
that's what we're talking about and so
here's a contrast okay that I make
between these things
an inventor must patent a device okay
whereas an innovator does not have to
patent the process and would rather do
everything to keep it secret and I know
a little bit about that because I served
three years in prison for it okay so in
my case was about exactly that point
there okay the fact that inter
corporation person the the group that
brought me in there right into prison
they said I stole their process and the
issue was you can't steal and intangible
you can steal that I can steal your shoe
and you can't use it right and that's
why we know that I have stolen it
but copy hey everybody copies a song and
sings it have you stolen the song every
time you sing it is is that what we're
gonna say and here we have the situation
where Intel did not patent their process
they considered it a trade secret and
they try to control them through
confidentiality agreements and so again
you say Oh hold it you didn't patent
your process of talking about process of
being part of an invention they don't
patent processes they don't prod they
want to keep them secret and they want
to protect them they want protection
despite that they don't publicly
disclose them so it's a way of cheating
on trade
bat-ball yeah and that's what they do so
how can you claim something as yours if
you haven't disclosed it to the public
through the Patent Office if you haven't
patented your process and in fact it's
the other way around that coca-cola has
not patented it's a process for
manufacturing coca-cola it allows them
to say if anyone out there so oh I
coca-cola and coca-cola will always say
no you haven't because you don't know
the secret the secret formula okay and
this is the issue the issue is that no
one wants surprise patent processes
partly because you want you know the
Chinese copying those processes and
doing it over there so that's part of
the reason you know a lot of processes
remain secret as trade secrets that's
the new wave okay anyways modifications
to an existing device is not an
invention but in innovation and
inventions deal with things innovations
deal with processes and with
modifications to inventions okay so we
have to distinguish those those concepts
okay what is other what is an invention
what is an innovation that's that's the
point I'm trying to make here and here's
a cartoon I think that puts it in the
right context okay the guys goes to the
Patent Office and he says you know he
says I'm afraid this new self you and
reinvented was has already been patented
he wants the patent his reinvent itself
okay is that a is that a is that a
patentable thing you would think because
the guy came up with an idea okay and
this is the issue the issues whether
some things are patented the bull or not
and I'm saying that patents have deal
with inventions and they have to be a
physical object they can't be a process
but then we're talking about the
question is you know can you can you and
if you made a green table instead of a
brown table are you going to patent the
green table and say oh I have it a new
inventions the green table is that a is
that a new invention the fact that you
painted it green instead of brown so so
this is the point that I'm trying to
make the fellow right now in this day
and age all we're doing is putting green
tables instead of brown tables that's
all we're doing today we we've already
got the invention Pesce of the things
that we absolutely need
and right now we don't you know we're
patenting these things to make money but
not because they are original devices in
any way okay that's that's the point
that I'm trying to make okay so here's a
again you know the fact that trade
secrets are innovations and not not
inventions okay and processes nobody
wants to patent them but the main point
here is that we have a problem with the
scientific definitions no one in the
last 10,000 years in science in what we
call science has learned how to define
word scientifically that's I think the
big problem that's that's my take on it
okay no one has learned how to define
words
scientifically in a way that they can be
used consistently rationally and so you
ask a biologist what is life
I mean biologists study life right and
they said well we don't have a
definition we don't know what life is
you go to the oncologist what do you
mean by exist oh I don't know I have all
these theories you know it's on and on
and on no one has ever defined the
crucial terms of their discipline you
know paleontologist was a mass
extinction oh we don't know we're still
trying to find out you know and so it
just goes on and on and so this is the
is the issue is that we don't have
definitions and so officially of the
crucial definitions the ones that make
them or break your arguments what is an
object what do you mean by exist what is
a mass extinction what do you mean by
life these words are never defined and
they say well that's not important
what's important is my theory well I
can't understand your theory of you if
the key word remains undefined and
that's the issue okay anyways uh we
patent inventions and inventions should
be public you know they have like 20
years protection different countries
have different times and so you have to
patent
this device and it allows you to make
money the inventor you know allows in
bank money for whatever time 17 20 years
whatever whatever every country
determines processes now they remain as
trade secrets more and more of them
nobody wants to patent processes that's
why that definition from the Wikipedia
should be wiped out because you know
processes are not or not are not being
patented they are pretend to Bowl but
they're not no one's patenting them
everybody wants to keep the process
secret it's the device they want to sell
ok ok so here we have the wiki
definition of patent and what this does
is put it in the right perspective it
says what is a path what do what does
the Patent Office consider patent took
bold ok so that must meet relevant
patentability requirements such as
novelty usefulness non-obvious
ok it's got to be something new it's got
to be useful in some way you know and
it's gotta be non-obvious and most
patent office in the world especially
the three important ones Japan Europe
and the United States they follow these
general rules ok these are rules of
thumb and the doctrine prevents the
patenting patenting of fantastic or
hypothetical devices such as perpetual
motion machines ok and what I did was I
added a couple more which are very
somewhat popular out there and puts
general relativity on the spot and no
wrong one if I get this one first and
goes like this this is the Alcubierre
drive which I'm showing there what
bribes to push against space-time you
know should we patent that is that a
patentable device ok
and I'm saying it's it's not here's a
Alcubierre drive just in case and you
can see that it pushes against
space-time okay so is space-time is a
physical object that maybe you can make
a ship run at the speed of light that's
that that's the point of the warp drive
of the word bubble in which the your
rocket would be in and so the question
is whether this is this is a patentable
notion is a something that you can
patent and I'm sure the Patent Office
would not accept this as a patentable
device in contrast you have this other
one which is the light sail okay and
this is a device that is working today
it's being pushed by lasers it's an
important an enormous kite essentially
it's being pushed by lasers the idea is
that eventually hopefully the Sun with
its what is it with its the solar wind
will push a light sail big enough you
know imagine something like they say the
size of the country of Turkey so we're
talking about a Norma's monster that we
have to put out there in space deploy it
the Sun would push it slowly with the
what is it with the solar wind whatever
that is right again I cover that the
couple weeks ago it's only ten to the
minus thirteen level of vacuum which is
almost an at or almost nothing but with
this faint solar wind they intend to
push this light sail and ever faster
speeds until it reaches I think it's the
tenth a tenth of the speed of light okay
so they're testing this thing the light
sail but you could say that the light
sail at least is a patentable device
just like you could say a kite is a
patentable device but the Alcubierre
drive work drive that's nonsense
obviously it's nonsense and and there
you see why they haven't uh patented it
because you can't know no patent office
would accept that the thing
okay so where does this take us this is
my definition okay I'm saying that a
adventure has to be an object can't be a
process and it has to have unprecedented
years and that's where all inventions
fail today because all inventions have
precedented used they're you know what
are you gonna do with the table make it
out of rock first you know that's what
the Neanderthals had you know a rock as
a table then we made it upward then of
metal and then we color the different
colors were those inventions there are
tables of tables at 8:00 so it's not
nothing new and can be made or used in
some kind of industry that's another
issue you know I mean one thing I
consider at least for for inventions is
does it put people to work I mean if it
just makes one guy rich pet rock for
example you know I don't think it's an
invention but this guy put a rock inside
a enclosure and sold it and make money
that you put an industry that you make
an industry those did this put millions
of people to work no I didn't it just
made him rich if anything I don't even
know if you became rich because of it
okay so I'm wondering about that you
know what effect does it have for for
the economy for for putting people to
work I mean if it's a device should put
manufacturing and blue-collar workers in
business if it doesn't and you know that
goes to the word use is there a use for
this because there's no usage millions
of people using it or demandingness and
you don't put an industry to
manufacturer what was the point of the
so-called invention was it just because
you had an idea and you and nobody wants
it that's the point I'm trying make and
then and again I get these notions from
what patent offices today think about an
invention and provides some identifiable
benefit again if nobody buys it then
what was the point of the invention
innovation cosmetic modification of an
existing you rice which is what we're
doing today we're doing a lot of
innovation
no invention whatsoever no way of doing
something process method that kind of
thing so I'm saying that's what that's
what an innovation is what we're doing
today is just innovating we're not
inventing anything
and so I distinguish those two terms for
those who you know say why did I say
that there are new no new inventions
yeah we have no new inventions or we
have our innovations we go to our
research and development departments and
they modify an existing device or
whatever that they have and they make it
better more faster more uses maybe
perhaps you know you know the fact that
you made a call with five wheels does
not make is not an invention a car is a
car a car and we can't reinvent the car
we can't reinvent the plane we can't
reinvent the wheel we can't reinvent any
of these things and so here are some
popular inventions that we've had since
ancient times you know the table the
chair wheeled bed maybe some kind of
pillow was a rock at one point in time
we made it softer right but it's the
look of little use we had for it right
pots and pans
acts you know we didn't invent the ax a
year ago no the S has been around for
quite a while club no banking club right
spear knife spoon boat you know you make
a ship yeah it's a boat sorry it's
already been invented
can't patent it all you can do is
innovate it and whatever you want to
call it innovation sword sling you know
they've been around for quite a while
what is not here are non inventions
according to me again okay let's put
this over here okay here are the non
inventions again fire is not a physical
object that's why fire does not qualify
according to me as an invention fire is
a combustion process
yes oxidation a lot of people don't know
that they sell fire I see something yeah
but it's what you're seeing is a
combustion a process domestication was
that an invention we call that in
eventually we go to the Patent Office
and patent domestication skinning an
animal left nipple feeding I like that
one you know I mean a woman invents you
know feeding breast feeding her baby
with her left nipple now should she go
and pasture
oh I've invented a new new way of
feeding a baby I'll do it with my left
is that a patentable device you know
Caesarion you know a lot of these
medical things they're not patentable
and there's many reasons for that
okay you should look that up surgical
procedures drugs and potions you know a
lot of that stuff some drugs and potions
in general are patentable but not the
surgical procedures okay vaccines that
patentable antibiotics you know should
we consider those as new devices or or
something these are the things you gotta
think about okay bank note we invented
money at some point in time say oh I've
got a new invention money is that an
invention does that qualify as one
language you know we invent a new
language baby does it says bad that goo
goo oh he's got a new language that I
I'm gonna patent that okay song someone
has a new song no we we take those to
the Copyright Office not to the Patent
Office right a lot of these concepts are
taken to the Copyright Office a
trademarks you know they're not
patentable that's a trademark you might
invent the word and call it a trademark
is that patentable no that's trademarked
customer lists they qualify as a pet as
a patent law you know legislature
invents stuff every day
chip process I know something about that
yeah you know the space specs
specifications is that patentable again
a process well they don't do that
anymore
they they keep it secret yeah computer
program is is that a patentable thing oh
I'm gonna patent my computer program
well a lot of these things are
considered patentable by the Patent
Office I do not consider bats I did not
consider them inventions okay but what's
the bottom line as far as I'm concerned
let's assume we we we invent something
something new I don't know going through
the fourth dimension
what should we consider that a a an
invention you know I make a device that
takes us back in time for example okay
you put this year you make the time
machine okay or something it takes you
through the fourth dimension or the
fifth time inch I don't care is that
gonna put billions of people to work
that's one of the issues I've got
because if it expands the blue-collar
worker force then you can say well this
is a pretty good invention because
there's demand for this thing and look
at all the factories that are popping up
and they're hiring blue-collar workers
everywhere they're paying them big money
just to come to the factory and build
this thing well that it ever happen ever
again on planet Earth and I'm saying of
course it won't I don't care what you
invent it's not gonna put billions of
people to work what we have today is
existing companies for example
electronics companies which are building
some of these things you know they buy
out someone they might buy out an idea
or whatever and they implement it so no
new company comes into being and says oh
now I'm gonna hire a billion workers
because I need to produce all these
widgets no such monster agriculture and
manufacturing are dying here here's the
little graph
and you can see what's happening with
manufacturing and and also with
agriculture agriculture is becoming a
smaller and smaller percentage of GDP of
gross domestic product and and
manufacturing is also going in the same
direction at least for high-income and
and at least for high-income countries
and I think it's also going for
middle-income countries as well it's
gonna eventually die out we're gonna
have less and less manufacturing not
only as a percentage of GDP but also as
a percentage of labour fewer and fewer
people are going to be working in
manufacturing and agriculture is almost
dying it's uh it's got almost nothing
it's like 1 percent of GDP and very few
people working it because we do a lot of
that with automation we're so efficient
on producing food and at distributing it
that you know that we don't really need
people and even if we produce
manufacturing in some way one of the
problems will be that we will probably
make it with robots or some kind of
automated system so we won't need humans
anyways to produce whatever
manufacturing device you invented so
even if like some say the technological
singularity where inventions will just
explode because the robots are going to
be doing the inventing for us they're
smarter than us these people are
dreaming just be better than they don't
have their feet on the ground anymore
if people are absolutely dreamers
they've been watching too much Hollywood
movies we're not going back to
manufacturing manufacturing is dying and
hopefully I can illustrate it here ok
that's what we have we have a hunter
gathering is dead been buried a long
time ago agriculture is on life support
and what happens the day that
manufacturing dies the blue-collar
worker there right well all we'll have
left is services and what is services
well services doesn't produce wealth but
services does is simply exchange
existing things
primarily I mean we also do service for
service but we're not creating anything
new we're not creating new highways new
buildings new wealth measurable wealth
all we're doing is exchanging
abstractions and the free we learn is
they don't understand that they think
there's nothing wrong with that they
they say well so what you know we have
value they talk about value they don't
talk about things you talk about value
because that's important to them what
can I say I think these people are
dreamers they don't realize what's
happening and what's happening is we
lost our ability to to keep our economy
running I think what's gonna happen is
as more and more agriculture dies and
more manufacturing dies we have less
wealth on the planet and that means that
all we will be doing for the next
billion years may be trillion years
we're just gonna be exchanging existing
goods or goods that we replaced but
there's gonna be no increase in goods
because manufacturing is going down
population is not increasing I mean I am
I the only guy seeing these things out
there I don't know that's what I see
yeah
anyways that's all I can give you I'll
give you my peace of mind I'll give it
to you as honestly as I see it free will
or Wheeler's free movies rulers free
will ease and narco caps they disagree
with me completely they say no no we
we've got it covered we're gonna be
trading for the rest of humanity and I
cannot imagine especially the people who
want to get government off their backs
and who say that corporations are too
big and it'd be nice if we chop them up
and have competition again what's that
gonna happen now what we're having is if
anything we have collusion among card
companies and defense companies and so
on you know they're their own in the
same boards right they all have the same
people in the same board they meet every
now and then they play golf together and
they reach decisions
they have this collusion out there if
anything there's mergers there's not a
breakup of companies to create
competition and so we have big monsters
out there and the day those monsters die
for whatever reason we're gonna have a
big problem so I'm gonna be taken over
by individual entrepreneurs that go in
and say oh there's no food oh I think
I'm gonna produce I'm gonna plant
potatoes because there are a thousand
dollars a pop because people are
starving and what are you gonna do wait
four or five months until the potato
grows is that what you're gonna do to
sell it at a thousand bucks to whom
who's gonna pay you a thousand bucks and
for what so again and all these people
are dreamers they're dreamers as far as
I'm concerned these people don't have
their feet on the ground anymore they
don't even know what they're talking
about that's my take on it you can throw
tomatoes rotten eggs but you'll have to
do them what is it on Wednesday next
time around okay
so we'll see you then and I'm gonna go
back to a moran one last episode I love
something behind when I digressed on
extinction coming back finishing that
off and then we go back into physics and
thanks again to all the supporters for
this year and I hope you all of you have
a Happy New Year
don't drink too much don't don't drink
and drive like I do
we'll see you that bye bye